the beginning of
markets what was a
market and when did the market that we
refer to it today because if you're
if you're talking to anybody and what
what the market do today and they're
talking about
the stock market but that certainly was
not always the case
well it certainly wasn't the case so
when you talk about markets i mean
markets themselves
think about you know the the most
traditional form of it is just a you
know you go to a souk right or you go
to a market where people are selling
wares you're effectively being
bringing together uh those who have
acquired goods and those who are seeking
goods right
um that's all a stock market is it's
just a market that happens to be
for pieces of paper that represent
various
corporate entities right and so most
people
tend to forget that history they don't
they think of it as differently than
going to the store because it is
actually different right
very few of us grew up in an environment
where we had exposure to a souk
or a you know uh
flea market sort of environment where
there's negotiating and haggling that's
going on
but that's all the stock market is is
it's effectively the meeting of people
who want to haggle over the price of
those pieces
of the paper what we refer to as q and
so the
the data that we see on markets is
actually just a history of transactions
that have occurred in those markets
right and that's kind of one of the
important things to remember as we think
about what markets are doing
there's buyers and they're sellers we
only see the inter
the intersection of those two where a
transaction actually occurs we don't
have any data in terms of what was the
market depth
we don't know how deep was the market
prior to the crash of 1987 we don't know
how deep was the market prior to the
crash in 1929
we don't know what the tipping point was
in terms of
those underlying components and for me
that's
the most interesting part about markets
is trying to actually understand what
happens when you step
just outside of where that transaction
occurred if it had gone another point if
it had gone two more points
was there depth that then would have
created a discontinuity
and that was really for me the most
interesting thing
that i've learned since coming out of
the theoretical background in high
school in college
is all of the models that we we use and
that we assume when we think about
markets when we talk about efficient
market hypothesis or we talk about
modern portfolio theory
or we talk about the crash of 1987 and
the assumptions that sat behind it
the assumptions are one of a continuous
market where you can always transact
and what 1987 really was was a
discontinuous market
it was a market where the next
transaction was so large
that nobody was willing to stand in
front of it
so when did the modern stock market as
we think
of it is this was was this a moment
under a tree in new york
uh in front of the new york stock
exchange as we know it today did it
precede that
well there are there are histories of
stock markets that go back to the early
1600s right so we have the examples of
the dutch stock market with the dutch
east india company etc so those
have been around for four or 500 years
but when we talk about a modern stock
market right there's never a
there's a contemporary stock market
there's never a modern stock market
right it's constantly undergoing
evolution
and so if you look back to the
buttonwood tree and i think it was 1789
in terms of the founding of the new york
stock exchange or what they
label as the founding of the new york
stock exchange you know you were trading
claims on companies primarily fixed
income there was some element of equity
trading that was going on
equity did not resemble what we talked
about today they were
in many situations full liability
corporations so your analysis would have
to include
could you be sued or could you be held
liable for the debts that were incurred
by this
entity over and above the capital that
had been invested
and those things have changed over the
past 200 years right the rules of what
we're transacting the definition of what
we're transacting the
obligations and rights associated with
that
have all changed in its most modern you
know form to use the language that you
you
you describe i would suggest that most
of what we think of as the stock market
today
kind of began in the early 1980s with
the introduction
of products like futures with the
introduction of
liquid option markets and
a tremendous growth of both fixed income
and
equity markets on exchanges
that might not have existed prior to
that right pink sheets for example were
actually a real thing
and there were many companies that were
not actively traded on exchanges
those rules began to change quite
dramatically with the introduction of
the dealer brokerage market the nasdaq
right the
national association of securities
dealers which created markets for those
etcetera
so i like i kind of would put it back to
that 1981 1982 time period which of
course feels like the beginning of the
the first you know great bull market
which i might suggest has actually
continued
um but that would kind of be where i
would start if you're starting to think
about it and again i was just very
fortunate to come into
a theoretical understanding of that at a
relatively young age
you know kind of 12 years 10 years into
the
the modern market to again use the
lexicon
um so along those same lines
uh when was when was the s p
500 when did that come about
in fact probably the next person i i
interview after you is
going to be a dear friend of mine howard
silverblatt who's he's only been with s
p for
i think 43 or 44 years now um he's a
walking talking spreadsheet it's just
frightful uh and when when there's a
shift in this index
it's it's a monumental moment inside s p
but how long has the spider you know
dollar sign sbx how long has that
existed
so the s p itself was created in 1957
um at the time it had only 200 stocks in
the index and then it was widened to 500
stocks
in a tradable format there used to be a
product referred to as
in the initial introduction of futures
there was something called the oex which
was the s p 100
that was far more liquid in terms of
trading activity
than the s p 500 was in large part
because the calculation
intensity the ability to get a computer
to very quickly run a replication or an
arbitrage construction on 500 stocks
was far more difficult than to do it on
100 stocks gives you some idea of the
advances that have occurred in our lives
used to take up entire rooms exactly i
very distinctly remember
um sitting in a
uh investment training course at spear
leads in kellogg where i worked when i
was
at penn and
you know a representative from merrill
lynch came in and explained that the
street now had
a full pentabyte of information
in terms of data that had been collected
in terms of the total amount of
information that was available on wall
street right and you
you stop and you think about how quaint
that is today relative to
you know we're all sitting around on our
desktops at the time i think the ibm
at had just come out and had a 30
megabyte hard drive right and so you
know that's a small
email attachment today um so
the world has changed quite dramatically
over that time period but
the the spx began in 1957
it was introduced in futures forum in
1982
um you know we can talk through some of
these components but you know one of my
favorite
uh references is actually going back to
that point warren buffett
in a 1982 commentary to the sec that
actually was then published in business
week magazine another
somewhat archaic reference um in 19
after the crash in 1987
it was brought to light that warren
buffett's commentary on futures was he
could
see a quote as i see logical risk
reducing strategy
that involves shorting the futures
contract i see no corresponding
investment or hedging strategy
whatsoever on the long side
and so when you think about futures and
and kind of the swashbuckling you know
paul tudor jones of the 1980s
what was really going on with futures
throughout that entire time period is
that they were the providence of
commodity traders they were the province
of people who were either looking to
hedge out their risk jim chanos famously
started kinacost advisors using futures
to offset
the equity market exposure exposing his
alpha for example
but nobody really had a use for futures
for another almost 14 years 13 years it
wasn't really until the mid-1990s that
we began to use them
in something that resembles their
current form where significant
use was was created on the long side